is the new Galaxy s23 ultra's 200
megapixel camera enough to destroy the
iPhone and the pixel well we've got
another unbiased camera comparison for
you but this time is a little bit
different Max is actually out in Florida
right now and he took a bunch of photos
Vadim and I have not seen any of them
we're gonna be voting on the best ones
so get a piece of paper and a pen vote
with us and let us know your results in
the comments so we got the first one
right here it looks to be a detailed
shot and right away I'm actually
noticing the middle one by far has the
most detail I don't know I can look
right here you could see all those
little hairs and even in the background
it looks pretty good too now the one on
the right garbage terrible one on the
left is also very good but I'm giving it
to the middle I'm actually gonna give it
to the left one for this one it does
look a little more saturated but I think
it looks better than the center all
right well let's see looks like we have
oh look at that s23 Ultra on the left
iPhone phone in the middle that's
actually the s13 ultra's 200 megapixel
mode versus 48 and the pixel 7 Pro has a
50 but it's binned down to 12 so that's
probably why it's not as good next one
Ultra wide on all three all right
instantly I see it's the one on the
right it has by far the least amount of
flaring from the Sun the HDR is the best
and detail is the best as well the whole
tree is so detailed and the colors look
really nice too all right we both chose
the right that's the s23 ultra all right
next up we got a portrait oh look at
that man the one to the left there is no
like Dimension or detail in their faces
the one in the center is just so cool it
doesn't seem like it's supposed to be
that cool honestly I'm gonna go with the
rights I kind of like the balance of the
colors and the blur also looks good
right is oh that's the iPhone next up oh
10x Zoom across all of them wow the
center is just bad terrible in the
center I mean this one has to go to the
right in my opinion yeah it just so much
more detailed you can see all the
textures and these leaves yeah the tree
everything
that's the s23 again and wait a minute
this is actually weird because the s23
has a 3X Optical while the pixel has a
5x obstacle and it's even worse than the
iPhone what the heck all right we got
another portrait and wow they're very
very similar this is a hard one well the
left one I don't know if it's just my
eyes but I don't see a portrait photo I
don't see any blur anywhere the one in
the center looks a little too soft for
me the details in the hair and the face
I'm going for the right I'm actually
gonna go with the one on the left even
though it looks like portrait didn't
really work I do think that it's the
least distorted that's the pixel 7 for
me iPhone you got the iPhone oh look at
that this is a portrait oh wow look at
the flaring this is all so flat flat but
the center one is not a portrait it did
not work but the one on the right the
car really stands out and looks great
what is that s23 yes that's good all
right we got a selfie wow what is
happening with the right one everything
is gray I like the left the best by far
is killing it so far whoa
whoa oh my goodness look at that that's
tough yeah yeah that's tough like he's
in the sun she's in the shade I mean
it's Gotta Be the center this one is
decent but like his shirt is all blown
out yeah colors are gone she's pretty
flat too and this is the last one too
and she's so dark yeah
Center is the picture what how does the
pixel
HDR oh 10 x Zoom Center for me yeah the
left one seems the worst the right one
looks a little little better and then
there's the center center
s23 it's killing it now before we move
on I've got to talk about our partner
Anchor's new 313 Ace charger 45 watt
which is powered by Gan technology
leading to higher Energy Efficiency
upgraded heat dissipation and reduced
size especially with its foldable prong
design so it's 30 smaller than Samsung's
45 watt original charger the
multi-protect technology safeguards your
Samsung Galaxy with 10 layers of
protection like over a voltage
protection current regulation and
overheating protection it's also perfect
for the s23 plus and Ultra because it
supports super fast charging 2.0 which
guarantees 45 watt Peak charging power
so you get a full charge in less than an
hour and it's compatible with all of
your other Samsung devices and of course
Android and Apple devices and if you
bought the regular Galaxy s23 anchor
also has the the 312 Ace charger 25 watt
which perfectly matches it with
guaranteed 25 watt Peak charging so if
you're looking for the perfect charger
for any one of the new s23 phones
anchors 313 and 312h chargers are the
ones to buy just search anchor Ace
charger online or use the link in the
description below color test what does
better okay right here blown out in the
background yeah
okay well when I'm looking at the left
one and I'm looking at their faces and
their hair okay it does not seem as
detailed they seem a little dark the
center one they're brought up they look
good yeah I do like the center as well I
like how the brights the highlights are
kind of popping even though it's not
blown out that sign got a little bit
there but that's not a big deal
pixels
wow all right looks like we have our
first video video so let's go ahead and
play this
Center the right whoa weird like motion
blur oh my goodness the center is like
unbearable to look at the right looks
the right looks good the right looks the
right looks really good look at their
faces all the detail all the colors
I like that
stabilization is excellent everything
here is so blown out yeah man that right
one and even at this pausing here at the
right looks detailed look at the tree
yeah yeah that kills it all right time
for the big reveal we have oh 14 pro Max
4K 4K AK
all right 3x sports right now this is
important because the pixel is not
taking advantage of the 5x Optical lens
it has to crop in from the 1X wow
there's some differences wow well the
left one is not portrait yep not at all
and that's Center on the right they are
completely different I mean the one on
the right is insane
you've got insane levels of detail what
no wait 14 from Max are you kidding me
Sunset HDR cool so no portrait this time
man immediately the center one she looks
golden she looks warm her skin looks
great that the sunset you can actually
see the sunset you can see yeah you see
the colors pop like that's the one thing
when you're experiencing a sunset in
real life you want to capture it from
colors and I kind of like that it's more
Moody you can see like the Shadows are
kind of brought down it's not like
middle of the day it's the iPhone again
wow Apple some I was able to bring the
colors out another video all right
smooth stabilization stabilization let's
go
okay oh what's with all the artifacts
and stuff on the left just see all this
yep yep yep and the right too the right
as well the left is oh no the center
okay well
I think the center is doing the best at
being smooth I see walking on the right
the center is just nice and smooth so
far
there was some Jitters motion blur too I
mean
yeah it's got to be the Sun for me I
guess lots of shaking us on the left
s23 Ultra is officially beating the
iPhone at stabilization where iPhone was
the king for so long five x Zoom so here
the pixel has the advantage with the
optical 5x geez that right one looks
terrible yeah the right one is garbage
it is so bright blown out flat I think I
see more detail on the feather yes there
is more detail it's got to be the center
for me now before I reveal which phone
I've got to talk about this the magic
stand case from our partner K school
which basically combines the best and
most Wanted aspects of a case into one
you've not only got a great and durable
design with strong Max Leaf magnets
built in but the max safe ring is
literally on a hinge so you can use it
as a finger grip or a 40 to 120 degree
stand and the best part is that it folds
back completely flush with the case so
it doesn't interfere with any other Max
save Chargers or accessories so check
out the link and all the discount info
in the video description below
pixel wish the pixel has to win that
with the 5x lens whoa that is cool I'm I
gotta say Center immediately that looks
sick actually Angelica I'm gonna choose
something else okay I feel like there's
just way too much yellow and warmth in
the center I like how the left one has
the colors kind of popping out more so
for me you want to choose the left just
yesterday we had a sunset that was
beautiful it was super pink and it made
everything pink and I feel like the
center one looks true to life I feel
like it would look like that
what did you choose you choose you chose
the iPhone I chose the pixel all right
on to the next one oh selfie video this
is front facing 4K video on one phone
this is the audio quality of the next
phone and this is the one of the third
phone
okay
so what does better so for me visually I
really like the center you can see all
the details in his face his hair his
beard his skin tone looks accurate it
looks warm but the audio as well I think
the center one sounded the best and
clearest I'm actually gonna agree yeah I
didn't like the one on the left the one
on the right was still pretty good but
the actual picture quality video quality
not it's kind of flat so I'm going with
the center as well
look at that that looks good oh wow dust
HDR so for me the center is instantly
out all of this over here and this just
looks so gray and flat compared to the
others I'm going with the left I like
how it's very sharp detailed sky looks
great and it's very moody so I really
like it I wanted to pick the right one
because it's darker and it's more Moody
but then I saw that it's just lacking so
much detail that the left one has
okay One X lens I like the center I
don't like the left how her face all
flat the right her face all flat it's
like a blown out middle you have
highlight roll off that's the iPhone
ultra white
ultra white night mode this is really
tough all three of these photos look
nearly identical but looking at them
closely I think I like the right one the
most so I actually have a different
opinion I don't like the left because
it's soft you can see like the brick
detail is very soft the right one looks
pretty good however I don't like the
over sharpening that I'm noticing in
this tree
pixel I have the iPhone again 2x
portrait okay so for me I do not like
the left something about their skin
their face their hair like it just looks
weird or artifacty on the right they
look a little blown out like there's a
lot of loss of detail in their faces I
think the center one is the most
balanced I agree I like the Highlight
roll off some very nice sharp detail
again all right One X night wow look at
that these are different the one on the
right I don't like it it's so just
yellow everywhere like look the boat
here is White House yeah hello for me
I'm going with oh man the center I feel
like it's so dimensional when you look
at it compared to the left one it looks
so 3D okay I also like the center as
well I'm looking in up close I see a lot
more detail on the trees the window
frame everything so the HDR when you
look at like that sign it looks much
more d detail that's 23 man
that looks big step up whoa yeah I'm
going for the right I mean just look at
all the details it looks so good yeah
this Center one's super soft 14 pro Max
once again wow 3x night mode is huge
compared to the others okay 1X mix
lighting whoa oh is he green yellow I
don't know I'm colorblind but man man
The Cider one I just don't like how flat
his face looks I guess I'm gonna have to
default go with the left it's got to be
the left and that's the pixel whoa all
right this one is out the one on the
right so much artifacting and noise
right here I'm not feeling it but the
center has no detail it's blurry
everywhere
is like a lot of kind of motion blur and
it kind of looks just so soft this one
has an ocean blur it does it does man
I'm still choosing the left I'd rather
have that because you have less noise
less artifacting it's darker in the
background it's still yeah I think I'm
choosing the lab
pixel pixel whoa
the budget phone is doing pretty well
right now Ultra wide night mode I'm
choosing the center even though it's not
the most detailed I do think it looks
better because the water is darker it's
more Moody you don't have a lot of this
artifacts weird noise patchiness there
14 pro Max all right this is getting so
close guys you have no idea these scores
are so close
wow okay oh
it failed oh my goodness well the first
thing I noticed is just how all like
this everything is crushed on the right
one like the photo is basically
only that but the portrait mode focused
on what are these guys called
storms red Stormtrooper apparently sorry
star Star Wars fans but look this was
all blurred out and then the left one
didn't even work I mean yes
looks very good s20
night mode
not the left one the left one is too
flat in my opinion yep soft flat I don't
like it I think I like the one in the
center the most I think his skin tone
looks accurate it looks normal the one
on the right just looks way too cool in
my opinion I'm actually gonna choose the
one on the right I like uh the detail in
his hair face it all looks really nice
and clean and I also like the depth of
field roll-off that that's the part that
looks really good on the right side
pixel
those are both really good photos really
really good oh geez Ducks I'm sorry but
that looks delicious choose the one that
looks the most delicious I just want to
eat it today okay which one do you want
the one on the right man that looks good
[Music]
caramel color yeah the color is much
better I like that it's a little darker
the center one's just a little too
bright yeah 14 per month
oh that looks good is it
is it just the right one look like it's
almost not in focus it looks kind of
blurry kind of like it blurred
everything out like I focused on one
point I like how it's super bright but
I'm sure it wasn't anything like this
I'm sure it was yeah low light honestly
I kind of like the one in the center I
was I kind of like that one I like more
detailed and stuff more probably
realistic
it caught up 3x night mode okay so this
is not a portrait wow okay this is tough
all right I mean I'm choosing the one on
the right so fast boom I'm choosing that
one it was so much better you can see
all the the strands of her hair this one
has so much noise everywhere and this
one has So Soft yeah yeah for sure I
like the right
dude snap guys oh okay on to the next
one for me the center one instantly got
out I I feel like when I look over here
it looks a little too over sharpened it
doesn't look
I think I see more detail on the right
side I am also choosing the right side
pixel wow okay so all right so the the
left one just looks a little too dark
however the right one like it's brought
up a little too much that's the hard
thing with night mode it's too dark or
it's like brought up too much it's hard
to find a middle ground when I look at
this area over here on the right side
everything looks really mushy
and I think the center one is a really
good balance yep I also like the center
one I like how the lights are not blown
out like the one on the right the left
one is just too dim you can't really see
their faces
I agree that's the picture
all right wow that's beautiful dude the
center one is all green and like swampy
yeah the sky is all gray something that
I noticed on the left one is that the
balloon really really Pops I also like
how the sky is darker and you can see a
lot of stars too it's true one thing on
the right you see like this almost black
dark glow like weird Aura yeah behind
that and it looks like the whole sky and
everything is kind of brought up and
gray it's kind of washed out so it's
kind of washed out the whole thing the
left is Just Killer just all the lights
stand out and the darks get dark
beautiful
[Music]
HDR all right Angelica oh man this is
tough the first thing I thought is how
the left one just looks much brighter
than the others and then I realized that
Alina is in this shot and I'm like where
is she in the center can't even see her
so between the left and the right I
think I'm gonna go with the one on the
right I like how the darks are dark like
the sky the one on the left the whole
sky is like brought up and it looks
already artifacty I am also choosing the
rights I love how the color of the red
pops yeah and all these lines are so
nice and sharp and detailed and at the
same time Alina is not just fully just
yeah gone crushed
wow oh that was the last one and we have
some scores and oh my goodness I can't
believe my results Angelica what are
yours this is crazy all right so losing
I got seven for the pixel yep rip pixel
and then I got 12 for the s23 and 16 for
the 14 pro Max wow and wow look at this
I got 13 for the 14 pro Max 11 for the
s23 ultra and 11 for the pixel 7 Pro
both of us had the iPhone win yeah can
you believe it the iPhone from last year
I mean the pixel is also from last year
but the s23 ultra even with 200
megapixels Mega pickles it ain't winning
for us I don't know you guys let us know
your scores down in the comment section
below this was fun we got more of these
coming in the future so click the circle
button to subscribe this has been Vadim
and Angelica and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
thank you